we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p there's this really unhinged
anti-semite who calls in very very often
and we usually don't play his voicemails
for a variety of different reasons here
is one that i do want to play for you
just to show you the type of stuff that
we're dealing with on a daily basis
hey you socialist you know you and 8oc
should go back to Argentina where you
belong
you're both a bunch of idiots you're the
bloody hemorrhoids on a hairy ass you
socialist all you want is votes for the
Democrats why don't you go back to
Argentina maybe you can wipe your ass
there what wait both your asses you an
AOC mmm no I'm not a socialist I don't
know why this keeps coming up but I I'm
just I'm not a socialist and the idea
that I mean listen alexandria Castro
Cortez is Puerto Rican by heritage I
don't and and she's American of course
as all Puerto Ricans are I don't know
why she would go to Argentina at all
necessarily and certainly I don't know
about going back to Argentina but this
is this is the type of stuff that day in
and day out we are fighting against and
this is why you're not going to convince
that person to change their vote right
get 10 people to vote who would have
stayed home because it is a waste of
time to try to change the minds of
people like that just don't do it that
can't be the strategy for the left in
2020 we've got a great bonus show for
you today I'm out of time to tell you
what is on it but it's a good one become
a patron become a member you'll get
instant access and I will see you then